Ghost Recon breakpoint is adding a free
immersive mode with its next update
here's everything you need to know about
the new experience plus another visit
from none other than Sam Fisher the new
update is called the ghost experience
and it lets you play break point in
three different ways
regular is the default mode with the
gear score and tiered loot you're used
to immersive mode has well none of that
then there's custom mode which lets you
tweak the rules of regular and immersive
modes to your liking let's talk about
those rules with immersive mode
specifically there's no gear level you
could be customizing the same weapon for
the whole campaign no quality tiers or
levels you can choose one or two primary
weapons and loot additional guns from
fallen enemies you can swap one of yours
for the one they drop reloading is also
more realistic if you reload your gun
with bullets still left in the magazine
you'll lose them additionally immersive
mode limits your health regeneration and
gets rid of most of the HUD regen and
HUD are some of the rules you can toggle
in custom mode to along with your
stamina level risk of injury from enemy
bullets and number of bandages you can
carry you can also turn on private mode
meaning you'll only encounter Story
characters and your own co-op partners
in erawan no matter which mode you
choose you'll still be able to play
online with friends lastly you can
toggle Maria's shop letting you access
it from bivouacs
or from within Erewhon only coming
alongside this big update is another
Splinter Cell crossover mission called
deep State the trailer features Sam
Fisher who's come to the islands to
extract a target known as the strategist
like the update this mission is also
free for all breakpoint players stay
tuned to game spot for some upcoming
impressions of immersive mode and we'll
see you on our own
[Music]